motif de la mort du rappeur icaunais nda
l'an 2015 restera mystérieux les deux
hommes qui ont paru qui ont comparu
devant les assises de l'yonne pendant
quatre jours n'ont pas voulu expliquer
leur geste basij des outils nous vous
retrouvons en direct d'auxerre où le
verdict vient de tomber les quelques
minutes seulement oui arnaud après
presque cinq heures de délibération le
verdict en effet viennent de tomber et
les deux hommes jugés son automne est
coupable d'assassinât et ont été
condamnés respectivement à 30 et 25 ans
de prison
avec dans les deux cas une peine de
sûreté des deux tiers l'après-midi la
préméditation a donc été retenue par la
cour et les jurés
les faits remontent à septembre 2015 et
les deux hommes sont condamnés pour
avoir étranglé brûler plus avoir jeté au
fond d'un puits aux carrières de michery
le corps du rappeur sénonais heimdall
alors âgé de 32 ans
la cour et les jurés sont allés au-delà
des réquisitions de l'avocat général qui
avait demandé ce matin je vous le
rappelle 28 et 25 ans de réclusion
les deux condamnés ont dix jours pour
faire appel de la décision
en direct de serre merci à vous